[Music]
right this is just the numbers let me
see if so people can say
you see there is some it looks like
quran it's like
but it's not quran but it's just some
stuff you see out of the movies i've
never seen this actually
yes it is and if you need to for for
example if you want to somebody have a
headache
you're going to do a black magic on him
and you want him to be headache always
all you're going to do going to recite
something put it in your neck can you
hold it up yeah here's this
assalamu alaikum greetings and peace
welcome to the dean show we have another
exciting episode for you
we have sheikh abu mujahid who is known
as a rocky how are you
alhamdulillah it's very nice to have you
in the studio
this is a very interesting topic many
people
are fascinated by this even the people
who say they don't believe because we we
we know that
it's innate in all of us to believe in
the creator of the hemison earth many
people try to cut some people small
minority try to cover it up
and then they'll start to believe in
ufos and
you know martians and stuff not knowing
that's potentially
the jinn right the world of the jinn
what got you interested to go into this
field
you're also an islamic scholar you've
been studying islam almost all your life
you're a student also of uh one of the
great scholars um
yes yeah tell us a little about yourself
and what got you into this specific
field that you've been
into for now for how many years it's
around 15 years 15 years yeah
what what fascinated you to go into this
specific because this is a specific
field now
you know that you decided to go into
healing people with the quran
actually it's a experience one day i was
at uh one of my relatives
and uh she have a little bit
uh evil eye at that time i don't know
what's the difference between evil eye
origin or these things
i believe there is a genuine evil eye of
course
what happened as they ask me to recite
quran on here
so i recite quran here but subhanallah
there is some reaction
i don't know how to control it so i said
what's wrong
the quran is words of allah and i
believe in allah subhana talah what's
what's going on
i cannot help her so after that i feel
guilty
how can i help the people so
alhamdulillah
i went to the some people who is a
professional and do this
to do this is uh we call it rakhi and
and i seek knowledge from them and at
that time i went to
do umrah i did actually at that time so
i went to
the bookstores in medina and
some other states some other city
i bought a lot of books i learned
alhamdulillah
from that time i step by step i teach
myself i learn
spend time and i ask a lot of questions
from the
people who have this knowledge
alhamdulillah
from that time alhamdulillah i'm in this
field
now people we know std sexually
transmitted diseases we
all know about what that but many people
they don't know about the spiritually
transmitted diseases
right the diseases that are out there
that now
it's something beyond medicine
it's something beyond you know the
normal it's kind of like paranormal it's
like you cannot the person's
gone to all the doctors they've seeked
all of the physical
means but then there's still something
is going on
i has maybe have about hundreds of cases
like this
one of the case that is uh weird
actually she have
half paralyzed the lady this is
particularly this is your patient yes
one one of my patients yeah yes
she have half paralyzed half parallel
paralyzed yeah
left side is not working what happened
her sister she is doctor
she knows what's going on and they came
from other state and when i diagnosed
the ask a question of course i
smile when i finish everything the
question i smile and her brother he
asked me why you smile
i said because i know alhamdulillah
what's the problem it is not a medical
it is not medical it is evil eye
so uh i said alhamdulillah may allah
subhanahu
wa'll help your sister but with the time
hours you will see your sister walking
inshaallah he
doesn't believe me he did not believe me
actually
and i recite quran subhanallah after
about
hour hour and a half left side became
shaking
all right shaking and even her legs
shaking
after about three four hours like she
wake up
and she looked straight and she asked me
who are you
i said i am abu jahed i said subhanallah
so she cried when she saw herself
she's walking so this is one of the
yani case that i have is
stick in my mind subhanallah now are
there
out of let's say 10 cases are there
because many people they rush they say
oh it's you're you've been possessed by
the gin
but some most of the time it's not that
it is not yes
is that how many cases are those a lot a
lot
a lot of people coming to my office you
know and they think that they have a gin
or evil eye of course you have to
diagnose to ask a question diagnostic
the problem
based of the answers i will know that oh
no you she have to see a doctor not me
yeah so there's a lot of cases where a
person just needs medical
medical or psychiatric psychiatric
doctor yes and then you also you can
differentiate yes
yes this is different i will just give
you one one different
if you recycle onto the guy or the lady
if she have reaction okay like cry or
shaking or numbness or headache
that means she have a problem i can take
care of her
but if she feel calm okay and she
doesn't feel anything
heavy numbness headache
okay i see that oh you have to see a
doctor there's a lot of symptoms i will
cover it inshallah yeah now what is uh
when you see because there's a there's a
lot of
nowadays it's also become something
that's prevalent out there
where i was listening to a
radio station when i was in bosnia
and they were actually advertising what
they called the siharbas where
the it's like the the the doctor
or how he translated in um from bosnia
and the
the witch doctor they were advertising
it on the radio
because you can come in and you know
people if they want this person to love
you
or they want to break up a family or
things like this that you go to see one
of these people
and then how can people differentiate
and is this acceptable islamically to go
see some people like this and what are
the signs that this is an actual person
because there's a legitimate case and
someone wants to go to someone they're
sincere
they want to go get help they know the
quran is a healing but now they go to
one of these voodoo
people right so what what's the
difference be someone someone doing it
correctly and one of these fake
yes imposters let's say about the fake
one yeah
okay first of all if you go to the
anybody
even if you have beard or you have a
good looking
if you ask you what's your mother name
if you ask me what's some other name
that's his fake
okay or give me your date of birth give
me your picture
so we got three things there he's asking
your mother's name
yeah yeah so it's like why is he asking
your mother's name it's related to the
jin actually oh
to the gym can we translate jin is like
spirits
uh jin is uh shaytan like
yes okay so that's three of them he's
asking for your date of birth your
mother's made a name or a picture
picture this is the the first thing
sometimes they did not ask you right
away
they will tell you okay you have a
problem without any information
okay and uh oh you have a problem with
your wife for example
all right how does he know that i have
problem with my wife
of course he contact with the jinn okay
so that's one of the the symptoms the
other symptoms is uh
if he give you the uh we call it taways
or uh
you know small papers
yes if he give it to you and maybe
sometimes you ask you to wear it in your
neck or
put it in your neck uh pour it in your
pocket
or put it in the bedroom somewhere
so the small paper he is not uh he's
gonna tell you don't
open it sometimes they said if you open
it you're gonna lose your eyes
okay it's a fake actually these things
of course when you open it
all right you will see there's the
numbers and letters
if you want to i will show you yeah you
have some examples yes
uh these things
for example you see this is a number
here you see
uh this is a number here so you've
gotten this you've got it from the
position this was in one of those
this is in there wrapped up yes yeah so
this is the one of them
yeah right this is just the numbers let
me see if so people can so these are
like some
so what we're seeing here this is like
some these are this is not quran this is
not quran this is like some kind of
codes here
code what are these codes for it is
related to the gene actually
i cannot spend that time why i have to
discord this because this is
it was my time yeah and this one same
thing it's the numbers
yeah the worst one is right here
it is this one now this is something you
can't like put around your neck
this is like a certificate you have to
put it
in your uh your bedroom they tell you to
sleep
that's not quran it is not quran but the
problem is
around that you see around that you see
there's a name
of jinn here those are the actual names
name of jinn of jinns yes that are
around this it is around
all around here yes it's the name of jin
now the people they don't know what's
the difference what is the quran but
they don't know what is the what is this
what is the name of jinn
sometimes sometimes he will give you
quran like a little course for example
but before i tell corsi there is a code
okay you cannot understand it you will
not understand it this occurred like a
number or anything like a star
that star or that code it's i do not
believe
so when you say i do not believe
bismillah
so that's mean i do not believe in quran
but you see the quran you did not see
the
the code yeah so this is one of the uh
symptoms of the we call it
or fake rocky okay other thing
other than this is
here you can get it from the internet
you can buy it from somewhere so now
they made a big business over a big
business for
yeah those people for example if i gonna
do a sahar or black magic on
to the people all uh the materials is
here
okay this is a needle for example
this is some stuff you see out of the
movies i've never seen this actually yes
it is and or if you need to for example
if you want to somebody have a headache
you're going to do a black magic on him
and you want him to be headache always
all you're going to do going to recite
something it's
and put that in his head here and he
will feel his
pain all the time have have there been
cases that actually people
have yeah i have these cases yeah yes
subhanallah so this is of course
it's easy to know obviously this is
prohibited in islam it is haram it's
prohibition
it's a kuffer this could take out of
islam doing this can take if you do this
you become a kafir not muslim
yeah if you do this these things you are
careful
so we're explaining to people this is
what people they they do this or people
go to people who do this
so we're giving them the signs of
someone who's
a what would you call this person then
what do they call these people these
black magic
what are their names we call it uh this
is we call it
for example or the we call it
the gel yeah the gel like he's a big
liar
okay we call him that the gel he's at
the jail so you need to stay away from
these people you have to stay away from
him
the problem is if you go there and
uh if you believe what he said
if you believe he's what he said became
out of islam
if you go go there and just to see for
sure
allah will not accept your salah for 40
days this is a hadith this is a serious
serious matter yeah for a hadith for
this if you go there and just to watch
just to watch okay allah will not accept
your your salah for 40 days
but if you go there and you believe you
become out of islam
subhanallah yes there are a lot of
people probably watching now
they have this around their necks these
around i
will show you something else to how does
this look like
okay
so these are now the the actual
okay this become like a superstition now
it's like this
yeah you put it in your neck all right
or subhanallah
like this put it in your neck can you
hold it up yeah here's this
see these are the things a lot of things
here you see in your neck
yeah okay you know so uh i have a lot of
this our uh you know
the red one is too so these are the
things that now
inside there is a paper like this these
so people these are these are things
that people came to you wearing
these people came to me with these
things about these things
the first question i asked him do you
have these things yeah
do you have these things if they said i
said okay give it to me
yeah so first first i have to cancel it
because this is a black magic it's
uh affected it's like it's active are
all these canceled now it's canceled
yeah i reset
as i said i ask him do you have uh these
tawis do you have
these things if they said yes bring it
to me if they said yes i have it in my
home i
tell them right away get it
and recite all quran like uh for example
you have
to cancel it it's easy yeah to cancel it
is easy
either you're going to decide surat
al-falak
it's easy so you just recite it for
people
who don't know the arabic you this is a
prayer and from the quran
from the quran yes asking the creator
allah for protection the protection to
cancel that thing
if you if you don't know just cancel it
just burn it
burn it you burn it sometimes you find
there is a
like powder powder that is serious
don't touch it to cancel it is you have
to get
water all right and recite quran on it
and surat al-falaq and sultanas put that
powder
on it okay keep it for three days after
that you can
uh borrow so if someone now has that
this is what they should do if they have
some of these what if someone
so they can they can uh recite the quran
over it
or just burn this burn it burn it burn
it but get it off your neck
on it and blow okay yeah and this is
cancelled
you can burn it what if someone says
well this is helping me they said
this is this is something that's helping
me i feel i'm helped yes what
yes you are right this is got the
question the people who went to the
those
fake iraqi this is a deal actually
between the rocky
or fake rocky and the jinn okay patient
coming to me
to him to a fake rocky and he will ask
him i need the help okay
so there's a deal between fake rocky and
the jinn
you have to take care of him just
temporary about three months
six months one year this is the deal
between fake rocky anderjin
okay so that's the deal now when the
patient coming to him
after that he gonna give him these uh
things that always okay
uh he feel okay just temporary or
the simpsons became reduced he he
doesn't have headache but he have a
stomach pain he doesn't have his stomach
pain but he have lower back pain
so this is a deal between fake rocky and
the genie to take care of him
temporarily but because he have to come
back to him
so he feel improve improvement a little
bit not always yeah
yes i've known k i've heard cases
where people they've also had let's say
some problem in the arm
uh somewhere in the body and now this is
a way
of the devil shaitan tricking someone to
associate
partners which is the worst sin
unforgivable sin that can land you into
the hellfire you know if you set up a
partner next to
to allah to god almighty the creator so
what they'll do is
now they'll say in the name of jesus or
they'll recite in some you know they'll
say something and then the jinn leaves
and the person thinks they've been
healed
but they've been actually tricked same
thing yes it's a deal
yeah i ask i ask him to leave he will
ask but before that
when i ask the genie to leave him i have
to worship
the jinn first yeah i have to worship
him first i have to
follow him for example before i became a
fake rock a big fake rocky
okay i have to commit cover
i have to commit that kuffar like not
islam like
he will ask okay go to the bathroom put
the quran in the bathroom
okay so this is the way that i became
rocky
fake rocky right after that he will
listen to me
whatever i ask him he will listen to me
he will do it
but as i said i sacrificed my religion
i became not muslim he asked me to put
that quran in the bathroom
or i i i uh write a quran
in the you know the generation write the
quran in narration
something something disgusting something
that takes you out of the religion
so after that that the genie he can help
me yes
okay so this of course this is not uh
islam this is
out of islam and any healing that
happens we don't say in the name of
muhammad in the name of jesus nobody
you're you're healing by the words of
god almighty allah in the beginning
in the name of you no you cannot the
name of anything even if the name of
muhammad is
no just in the name of god just in the
name of allah
just bismillah that's it in the
beginning we have to make of course
bismillah okay and we after that we're
going to make dua and these things
inshallah have you seen people also
working with
with um they just do some really and i
and i think that
your intuition tells you hold on
something's wrong here how much should
you follow your intuition when
people are working with animals chickens
doing some really weird
things that have nothing to do with
islam have you also seen
yes i have their cases and uh
when they're people because they are
struggling they need help from anybody
they hear somebody somebody in north
south whatever
so he went to ask him help the first
thing they ask you
for example give me pidgin okay pigeon
so when he did he's he killed the pigeon
in your shoulder
yeah and he did not slaughter that that
you know he
he put you like his hand to kill the
pigeon all right
so that's mean he sacrificed when we
he sacrificed in the name of the jinni
you
use that pigeon okay so he killed the
pigeon in his
shoulders okay and uh
he will ask you as i said the fake
rocker he will ask your pigeon or ask
you anything
like rice he'll give you rice he gave
you eggs
lemon and sometimes he put the nails in
the corner
nails in the corner all right so that is
the fake rock of course
you have to stay away from that one we
want to get your reaction to uh
to one of these
i i don't feel i don't feel pain now it
just looks like you know it it was here
it moved the pain move from here and the
head is very light now
that is a case of sahar of course i have
cases like this
like this exactly yeah just like this
like this yes so what did
what was he he what was he doing now he
seemed like he just snapped
out of something over no he had he had a
genie
what does that mean what he is
what was he saying constantly over and
over
is it black magic he kept saying it's a
kind of uh it's a part of arya
yes
so when somebody has her black magic on
him
i keep repeat
the patient will feel relief after that
and so this was a legit
yeah yes yeah it is it's a jin well it's
clear
and this is because he after that became
wake up oh
alhamdulillah i'm fine so i have kissed
it like this
how does this impact you now for someone
to see this
and now does this just even increase
your certainty
like your iman does it go up for many
people of course
tell us about this what happened is
subhanallah in the beginning
we believe allah subhanahu ta'ala we
believe angels we believe that into
uh allah created everything
alhamdulillah but when you see
the reaction okay when i say
a little bit reaction like shivering and
cry
i said subhanallah this is a part of
quran and that's to cancel the
evil eye that area
to cancel even i when the the evil eye
cancel
from your body you feel really really uh
shivering after this
relax it's everything is gone so feel
that alhamdulillah
quran is the words of allah we we
restart quran to help the people and
allah subhanahu ta allah will help him
now what's the proper way so we gave
some examples of the fake
the the liars the uh these fake
magicians who are out there
and now for people to know like what is
it's
really a simple what is the right way of
of doing the healing
the right way is a good question
according to the quran and the sunnah
yes first of all uh
we have to ask questions symptoms like
we have to deal with the
black magic or evil eye or possess as a
sickness
like a flu like a cancer
these sickness have a symptoms like if i
tell you
if you have headache and shivering and
hot or cold and swallow difficult to
swallow
right away gonna say i have a flu right
the symptoms of the possess or black
magic or evil eye
symptoms same thing we're going to deal
with as a sickness
uh these symptoms of for example
headache okay now if you say i have
headache i will ask you which part in
your head
because the part of your head it will
show me you have evil eye
or black magic right so if you have
a headache again most of the people they
have it from here
if you have it from here right away i'm
going to tell you we have
heavy in your shoulders feel weight in
your shoulders
if you have uh palpitation
with no reason i have gas
or acid with no reason with no medical
reason that's what i meant
if you have stomach pain lower back no
no medical reason knees pain and
numbness
numbness with no reason not you are not
diabetes for example okay
and you feel that you want to cry
cry for no reason uh you feel sometimes
like a shadow
cross in front of you or something
behind you just feeling there is nothing
if you have constipation for a woman if
the monthly period
is not coming regular like not normal
okay
and you have anxiety
if you have rash in your body no medical
reason
around sunset time and sunrise time
you feel more anxiety more depression
okay uh sleeping problem you cannot
you have to spend hours before you get
sleep
while you are sleeping you get twitching
twitching
with no reason as i said if you have
dreams you see a snakes
okay uh dogs uh any kind of animal
often like snake if you snake every like
one one
every month two teeth two or three times
sometimes every night
people so they have it if you're falling
down in the dream
if somebody chasing you in the dream if
you fly
in the dream if you have sexually dream
a lot
if you have now when you sleep you will
sleep in your stomach on left side
you cannot sleep in the right side in
the beginning yes maybe when you do ad
car
morning time or even before your sleep
amina rasul and
you have to remove to from right side to
left side or stomach
and if you feel that somebody's next to
you while you're sleeping
when you come to your home you feel
tired
in your home you feel if if uh if you
you hear sometimes footy steps but
nobody
or knocking but nobody sometimes you he
you feel like uh the the light flicking
or the door open and close by itself
i have video like this in the uh
so it's door closed and open without
anything
what do you mean you have video of this
that's in my uh
no you don't just tell us like you've
you i did not the people
before i go there yeah i went there they
uh they record it ah to show it to me
yeah so they send it to me
this is like just paranoid these are
actually that's unexplainable i mean
they
yes they said that what happened is why
this story
the people before they call me
uh i mean uh when they called me they uh
they said that there's something
happening to
my home i said okay what's going on uh
the lady she asked me please come so i
went there
said what's going on she said out of
sudden i feel headache tired and these
you know the symptoms that i told you
and uh i ask questions
one of the question is did you uh play
with the ouija board
ouija board you know that that box is
called the gin come
yeah yeah so one of the girls she said
yes
i said from that night you have this
problem
he said yes from that night ouija board
all you gonna do just uh ask a question
i see that the pin
or the the things is pointing to the
letter
okay and you write it so from that time
they call the ginny
from that night the the the
the light flicking out on and off the
door open and closed
so that's in inside your home
okay so this is the symptoms what's the
difference between
now are there some symptoms that you did
are these all of them or these are the
main ones are there other symptoms not
all of them no no no there's a lot of a
lot of you know how about when have you
noticed
some people who are just very
argumentative like belligerent like they
a switch can go off and then they just
become very like
it's not them someone just acts like
they're
they're not themselves like they just
act like you would
only describe it if you describe it like
a shayateen like someone who just
they have you had those cases where
someone is just acting abnormal
if he acting abnormal with quran yes he
have
he is possessed yeah but he is acting
without quran
okay i'm going to tell him go and see
under a doctor so this is the difference
that's the difference
if it doesn't have these symptoms yeah i
have uh
one of the cases uh
like she came from other states yes
and her husband he told me she have a
gin all right
right away uh when she came to my office
she said i have a gin i have a
jewish gin and i have a thousand with me
so you cannot beat me i said okay no
problem
how did she know this already that's yes
this is what happened
i ask the questions none of these
answers is yes
you have headache no i have a heavy on
your shoulders no no no no but i have
ginny
it's yanny it's obvious that she doesn't
have ginny
and i said okay i will uh give you
something
it will remove the genie from your body
so i give her water
i said this is a quran this is a war
it's a unique war
when you burn it when you drink it
you feel burn in your stomach so
right away she uh she drink
water and she feel burning in the
stomach she said what is the water that
you give it to me
burn i'm die i did see this what the
jimmy said in
in she believed that as you have a genie
and i
said okay i'm fine now i'm feeling clear
finish
okay but the water that i gave it to
here is normal
i i actually put it next to my mouth
that
to show here that i am resigned to quran
well quran but i did not resurrect yeah
okay i gave it to her i said okay your
drink it you will be fine she'll drink
it she'll be fine
yeah when i finish everything i told her
that you had it doesn't have journey but
you have a fake
we call it uh internal mind the internal
mind and external mind internal mind
controlling your mind so you believe
that you have a gin
i said uh i asked her do you have this
jenny before about two or three years
she said yes what happened is one day
she watching movie
the youtube the movie and that one of
the these things
is uh
the rocky here is the quran to the lady
and the lady she said
i have a jinny a thousand i'm a jewish
and you cannot beat me
i said from that time you have this this
uh sickness she said yes
so it's a fake yeah so it's a fake
possess we call it
fake poses it's easy to find it
i'm sorry it's not easy to differentiate
to make difference between this and that
the real possess and fake process
you have to get more study you have to
learn more but you've got
you've gotten to a point with your
experience that you can you can
differentiate yes
yes yes what go ahead the eyes too
and when you're is arisat on the eyes if
the
the lady she doesn't have eye contact
with you
when you sat quran she tried to run away
from her eyes that's mean she is
possessed
yeah what's the difference between the
black magic and the evil eye
black magic is uh you have to go to to
guy
who doing uh black magic all right or
you can download
to go to the internet to do by by the
things
okay and uh you have the black magic
these different kinds
a lot of different kinds of like high
black magic and white black magic
high black magic and low black magic
right white black magic
and lower black black magic so that's a
lot of uh difference
uh times uh the black magic you need
materials
you need uh mother name you need date of
birth picture anything from him
clothes for example and
it's difficult to do it to make it it's
difficult to make it
now evil eye is easy to give it to the
people
if you get jealous from anybody
sometimes the people they give
jealous if they get jealousy from the
anybody you have uh
more money than me have a nicer car than
me
you have more kids than me okay let's
get jealous of him
okay so when i see for example you have
nicer car than me i said wow you have
nice car
you will get problem to your car or you
have a good hair
you will get your uh problem with your
hair you're going to lose your hair or
you have a big
body yani you have a muscles you're
going to lose your muscles
so these i give you evil eye all right
after that you'll be you get sick now
evil eye is a three kinds as
the evil isaac three kinds hot evil eye
cold evil eye and tired evil eye
hot evil eye the people who get evil i
get effected from evil you feel hurt
with no reason it's affected your
hydrogen
in your body so stuck in your chest
okay you feel heavy and you feel
head pain in your uh back and then back
of your head
you feel heavy numbness hot you cry for
no reason
and constipation hot evil eye if you
have it
it will takes you to the physical
problem like cancer
like diabetes depression like diabetes
blood pressure this medic medical
problem
now cold evil eye you feel shivering
cold with no reason okay it's affected
you in
nitrogen in your body it will takes you
to the
mental problem psychiatric problem like
depression anxiety
the end of this stage evil eye the end
of this stage is
to have sexually dream a lot flying in
the dream
and to think to kill yourself
and i have cases that people one of the
case he killed himself
because of that yes so you you actually
had someone i have one some somebody i
told him
i have to see you right away but he that
that did not come
and then he ended up he didn't end up
seeing you yes and then he ended up
committing suicide
yes are there some of these cases where
they give the diagnosis let's say
schizophrenia
and the people have tried all different
types of medications
and and everything has just hit a hit a
dead end because you got to give some
name for the problem
are there cases of schizophrenia or
whatnot that can possibly be it is yes
it is
yes just before three days there's one
lady she was in the mental hospital okay
she spent about 10 years
uh 10 10 days after this alhamdulillah
i asked a lot of questions the whole
answer is yes
the the the question to ask the whole
answer is yes
so i know that you have evil eye so
after that subhanallah
i recite quran on her and she feel
relief
and she said this is the first time from
long time if you relief
the medication is not help i'm not gonna
say everybody have evil eye no
as i said you have to first of all you
have to check yourself with the
quran if you know there is no problem go
to that check yourself with the doctor
yes now what happens if people do you
find some people
reluctant to go ahead and get the
treatment
with the quran what do you do in that
case is it not that's
difficult to help him if he doesn't
believe if he doesn't believe that he
have a problem from
evil eye or from jinny of shaytan
i cannot help him they have to be
willing they have to first of all you
have to believe that the quran is a cure
yeah as a quran okay and if he doesn't
believe oh i don't have ginny i didn't
i don't have uh evil eye i cannot help
him i have to sit him
to sit with him uh to convince him if he
doesn't uh believe
i cannot uh help him have you had some
people who are not muslims come to see
you and want help
so what happens in that case where they
they they don't believe
they're not muslim they do not believe
subhanallah and uh
they when the lady she came girl she
came
and she uh she told me that i have vedic
the that lady she have a friend
she have an evil eye and she you know
they share the
you know the experience with between
them she said i went to the imam
and alhamdulillah i'm fine she said i
feel the same thing so i need help
so the both of them they came to see me
alhamdulillah
i told him that there's a word of allah
subhanahu ta'ala and this is a
relief from allah subhanahu wa ta'ala so
i i will ask allah subhanahu for help
and i will recite quran on you so will
you you will feel it during the
the you know the state during the
the quran and during the uh when i said
quran you feel headache
you feel numbness you feel sleepy you
feel tired
after about our hour and a half you feel
relief
so after our hour and half alhamdulillah
she feel relief she said i feel
alhamdulillah
lighter relief calm even vision became
clear alhamdulillah
so this is you're alive yes and after
this alhamdulillah
i gave her the quran yeah and i said
please read the quran
alhamdulillah after that she converted
to islam oh she accepted this
yes masha allah so what can
alhamdulillah this is amazing to hear
these things what can a person now
do that they can protect themselves
what are some of the things that you
should be doing on a regular basis
yes uh there is a book this is fortress
of muslim
yes yes yes so this is the the book that
i trust
i believe that alhamdulillah everything
you need
to protect yourself it's there for
example
uh there's a paragraph morning time
before morning time you have to finish
that paragraph
evening time you have to finish that
paragraph uh before you sleep
same thing you have to finish the
paragraph before you sleep
when you go to the bathroom for example
say bismillah
would become this is allah to protect me
from the female and
male jinny that's the meaning when you
eat
say bismillah when you sleep when you go
inside your home
say bismillah these things it's not
everything of course
everything you have to always you're
going to say oh would you believe energy
okay that's protection aware of to do a
haram
salah for example jamaa that's a
protection
dua is a there is a protection now uh
if you do alhamdulillah and you did
the paragraph of from fortress of muslim
now you are protected from allah subhana
tala the whole day
but the question is is that protection
is broke or not sometimes
it is sometimes if you disobey allah
subhana
or you committed any sin that protection
is
cancelled so we have to redo it again
renewal again like for allah
alhamdulillah
repeat the names of allah after salah
that is very important after salah you
have to do
like al-kursiy for example
that's like renewal the protection one
more time from the beginning
so the whole dua the book i prefer that
every muslim should have it
okay that's the whole dua it's there
alhamdulillah that you need it
the you need it and there's a protection
yeah you know
don't deal with the haram things don't
listen to the music
because that break your protection don't
deal with the
you know uh the things that allah
subhanahu ta'ala doesn't like it
and now especially do you have some
people that come to you and they're not
praying five times a day they don't have
that right that connection that they're
not implementing islam
but then they come to you and what do
you tell them then i mean
at the end you should be living this way
of life from from the creator
24 7. yes
most of the people when they're coming
uh
you know some people they don't pray
yeah
in the beginning i give him like advice
give him like uh
allah subhanahu ta'ala created
so you have to follow the quran if you
do not follow the quran the shaitaan
will attacking you
if you do not follow the quran and the
sunna will attack again they could
possess you too
so you have to believe in allah
subhanahu wa you have to
pray five times a day so i give him like
a
small speech about how to do uh salah
for example if they don't praise allah
if they do not make wadu they have to to
teach them
uh give them some advice a little bit
about islam
you know give them just uh something to
encourage them to
practice islam yeah this is very
important because
in the beginning yeah so if they they
let's say you break that
you get that jin out of them then they
go back to their old ways
that is another problem yeah most of the
people when they became
fine allah gave them relief they became
lazy
they said okay alhamdulillah i'm fine
that's why i have to go
to practice one of these things the
shaitan is attacking
again i know that uh for example if the
patient coming to see me
i give him uh the materials they give
him quran
quran you know after like about two
three months he will come back
said uh the problem is coming back to me
i said okay the the materials that i
gave it to you
the way that i give it to you to to stay
with allah subhanahu wa tala
not practice he said yes because
praise allah he became lazy to listen to
the quran
became lazy he listened to the music for
example he deal with the
anything is haram so he did not practice
of course after two three months the pro
the the sentence coming back to him
so we have to practice always okay this
is the reason
yeah so that allah subhanahu created us
worship him
exactly yeah so that's how you get the
protection correct yeah
very enlightening inshallah we can have
you back again